je viens effectivement vous presser
d'investiguer bien au-delà du cercle
d'imputabilité définie par la justice la
justice traite le crime en fonction du
champ des possibles mais la vérité
judiciaire ne condamne que ce qui est
pénalement répréhensible et néglige la
responsabilité politique celle qui prône
le respect des droits fondamentaux
l'ordre républicain et l'intérêt commun
il n'y a plus que cette probité de
façade qui laisse ouvertes des brèches
immenses permettant la réalisation des
actes les plus odieux c'est en ce
contexte là que l'absurde est devenu
réalité mon frère a été décapité le 16
octobre 2020 3 ans après il estant de
réaliser que la fameuse phrase lancée
par Monsieur Blanquer il y aura un avant
et un après Samuel Patti n'a pas eu les
effets attendus on pourrait aussi
soulever les mécanisme du non dit de
l'éducation nationale là où on parle
d'élèves et de familles compliqué jamais
difficile ou tout simplement impossible
à gérer et refusant de s'insérer dans la
société française l'administration
préfère juger que les professeurs sont
en difficulté et que les chefs
d'établissement sont insuffisants
effectivement ce qu'il faut surtout donc
ça retourne sur l'islamisme il faut faut
mener un combat
idéologique parce que en fin de compte
les mesures correctives on va protéger
un professeur évincer un élève le mettre
dans un établissement on va faire
convoquer le père de famille qui a pu
menacer et qui sera jugé souvent sous
des peines qui sont tout à fait
négligeable donc en fin de compte ça
entraîne récidive parce qu'en fait on
déplace les problèmes c'est un petit peu
comme si on appuyait sur un cancer et
qu'on disème des cellules cancéreuses un
petit peu partout
donc voilà par rapport à ça pour moi
c'est c'est vraiment un combat que tout
le monde doit mener contre l'islamisme à
l'heure actuelle qui effectivement est
en pleine offensive et qui va de plus en
plus vite mon frère a été reconnu par
certains et à tort coupable de déloyauté
le cût de sa désobéissance sera qu'il
finira seul et que l'État n'ura pas sa
part du contrat social en lui assurant
protection le dernier condamné à mort
pour blasphème en France n'est plus
François Jean Le fève de la barre
exécuté en 1766 à abeville c'est
désormais Samuel pati exécuté en 2020 à
Conflant
saint-onorine combien de temps vous
faudra-t-il pour comprendre que la
culture de la Libye soit religieuse soit
ethnique est utilisé pour commettre les
pires exactions finalement à vouloir
éviter discrimination et stigmatisation
cette attitude amalgame et réduit au
silence ceux qui pensent comme frère que
je cite la vie de l'homme est le droit
le plus sacré quand-il appris après ça
si je vous dis rien c'est désespérant
mais c'est la réalité est-ce qu'il y a
que l'horreur de ce vendredi 13 octobre
qui va me donner
raison